on vous a souvent parlé à l'émission des
dangers des dib fixe c'est hyper trucage
conçu grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle ou encore des dom fixe ses
vidéos truquées conçu de manière très
rudimentaire mais qui alimente tout de
même la désinformation
alors maintenant imaginez les géants
twitter et facebook
agir contre une telle vidéo qui a été
relayée par nul autre que le président
américain
c'est précisément ce qui est arrivé
cette semaine jeff allons-y étape par
étape morceau par morceau commençant par
la vidéo comme telle qu'est ce qu'elle
contient ce dock été publiés par dun
scavino qui est le directeur des réseaux
sociaux de la campagne dans l'offshore
et on voit joe biden dans l'avenue il
semble le dire
on peut juste j'appartiens
en fait c'est un vrai discours qu'il a
prononcé mon a coupé la fin de sa phrase
j'étais dans le reste de la phrase joba
renzi on ne peut que faire élire dans
notre up
si on mène une campagne négative et il
faut qu'on soit positif pour google et
twitter à apposer la mention comme quoi
la vidéo a été manipulée donc ça
apparaît pour les gens qui partagent
abdoul elah dire twitté par le président
lui-même dans les territoires et par le
compte officiel du président a par
plusieurs de ses supporteurs parlons
justement de ce que tu viens de faire si
tout était à procéder à cette
appellation c'est parce qu'une nouvelle
politique ce sont juste une première
c'est la première fois que twitter a
pose cette étiquette la vidéo manipuler
bon ces nouvelles politiques de twitter
en prévision des élections
présidentielles 2020 on veut y discuter
les vidéos qui sont manipulés une
politique similaire chez facebook depuis
un certain temps on chez facebook on
retire des vidéos qui ont été manipulés
par l'intelligence artificielle donc les
fameux dit fake
parce que si ça n'appliquerait pas parce
que c'est simplement la un montage un
peu trop jeune homme fait on fait
exactement
donc j'ai pas de grandes technologies
ils étaient déployés pour créer cette
vidéo là chez twitter on la retire pas
on fait juste mettre une étiquette
en dessous la vidéo qui dit attention
manipulation alors twitter a été d'une
part applaudi par ce geste mais d'autre
part aussi critiqué comme quoi c'est pas
parfait dans les systèmes communs en
place
c'est justement on respire pas la vidéo
d'une part on met un petit avertissement
qui est en bleu en dessous de la vidéo
ainsi post super évident en fait si vous
allez sur le compte de deux options puis
vous regardez la vidéo aujourd'hui
l'étiquette n'apparaît pas qu'il
apparaît seulement quand vous le voyez
dans votre fil d'actualités ou est un
donc déjà là il ya un problème le disque
est à peu près pas toujours l'équipe de
trump s'est défendu en disant bien on a
simplement fait un montage comme
n'importe qui le font les médias le font
on prend une conférence de presse de 30
minutes et on sort un clip de 14
secondes donc qui va décider qu est ce
qui constitue un montage quelles sont
les intentions derrière ça ça pose
toutes sortes de questions au moins dans
le projet de facebook ce sont des
journalistes qui font la vérification de
fait pour déterminer si une information
est trompeuse
dans ce cas là on sait pas qui vérifie
ça c'est selon les politiques un temps
donc ça laisse beaucoup à désirer cette
pratique c'était bien n'est parfait
alors que s'approche à grands pas comme
tu disais la campagne présidentielle aux
états unis on a bien hâte de voir ça
[Musique]